well it's so funny too because I've been
telling to really clean up the room it's
like God it's not like everybody hasn't
heard that fifty thousand times yeah
it's become this meme but the reason for
that is because I tried to explain to
people to everyone including me why it's
important to clean up your roots like
hey man you have a room yeah it's like
most people throughout human history
have not had a room you have a room on
my room's a hell hole it's like well
then you're a denizen of Hell inhabiting
it you should do something about that
well what well put it in minimal order
get your clothes together because you
have to wear those and that's known
people that people are looking at your
clothes Oh get your clothes in order
what clothes should you be wearing not
the clothes of a total wretched loser
how about that you know Tasmanian Devils
and stuff like that right exactly well
and what about your bed well is it
comfortable do you make it in the
morning so it looks like half civilized
can you sleep there it's like is there
junk everywhere so you just hate your
life when you walk into your room it's
like cleaning the damn thing up yeah if
you can do it order your drawers learn
to fold your clothes you could probably
learn that put it in minimal order and
then man you could get spectacular oh
you said put a plant in there it's like
a plant well then you have to learn how
plants work and then you have to water
the damn thing but then there's
something living in your room you might
hope my room is the sort of place where
something could hypothetically live like
yeah yeah like you exactly and then you
might actually start to live well you
might you might if you set the stage for
it you might start to play the part and
anything wow that's it maybe I could
make it beautiful it's like then not
only would you have a room if you want
to get opposition from people around you
who aren't happy about you trying to
improve things
cleaning might not do it although it
might because people think who the hell
do you think you are cleaning up your
room it's like you know yeah are you
better than me it's like oh maybe maybe
maybe thank you for a second maybe you
think you can think you are maybe man
maybe you know if you're if you're maybe
that's your brother your older brother
or your father he's all covered with
Cheetos dust and his guts hanging out
he's watching TV smoking a cigarette
thinking oh you think you're better than
me eh it's like well yeah there's gonna
be resistance but you that'll be nothing
like the resistance you'll get when if
you try to start making your room
beautiful
man that'll produce resistance because
beauty is absolutely terrifying to
people because beauty beauty highlights
what's ugly and so if you start to make
your room beautiful that everything
around that isn't like that just starts
to glow I mean like in the in the in the
worst sense so is that dangerous though
yes that's terribly dangerous that's why
people are afraid of beauty but it's the
greatest thing you can do because it
puts you in alignment with like
beautiful things are beautiful for a
reason right that beauty has depth like
it's real depth man that that's what
gets you in touch with the transcendent
and the divine is beauty you introduce
that into your room you're playing with
fire and people will resist it and so
you can think well first of all I'll
make my room Spartan and clean and neat
sort of like military level discipline
like clean it's like okay now you got it
cleaned up and then you think my clothes
are in order I got it cleaned up now now
maybe I'll try to I'll do something
it'll make it beautiful well then you
have to learn what beauty is too and
that's really hard nuts and that'll be
scared it's gonna be scary because if
you're a dude you can't yeah well you're
also gonna think well what the hell do I
know I have terrible taste which
undoubtedly true yeah so do your best
you know get a print of something get a
print of a great painting put it on your
rooms like you think oh I don't know
what they all that thing's doing there
it's like look out man that thing's got
power
so look think about it this is I was in
this museum a while back in New York and
it was I don't remember which museum it
was in but it was full of these
paintings from the late Renaissance and
so they were there's like a dozen of
them in this one room mhm and and like
by people like Michelangelo and Rodin
stuff like that Rodin would be later but
the same caliber or caliber of artists
same caliber and so I was in that room
and that's like every painting on that
wall was worth 300 million dollars like
minimum you couldn't buy those paintings
like they're priceless but if they were
ever went for market it'd be that's
about what they'd be worth it was like a
dozen of them in there I thought wow
there's like 3.6 billion dollars worth
of paintings in this room and then
there's people all over the world
they're coming to look at these
paintings and you think okay look here
we are we're in the richest city in the
world prime lo Pramila state in this
unbelievably expensive museum in this
sealed room the paintings are worth 3.6
billion dollars
and people are making pilgrimages from
all over the world just to look at them
it's like what the hell's going on it's
like yeah no kidding what the hell's
going on there's beauty in those
paintings there's beauty and it's
magnificent and part of what it does is
say you aren't who you should be
that's what beauty does to you it's like
you aren't that's why you're intimidated
by a beautiful woman a staggeringly
beautiful woman it's like oh my god
you know attracted for sure but
definitely intimidate it's like well
that's cuz you aren't who you could be
beauty does that to you because I sew up
because I'm not who I could be mmm yeah
well because beauty has that contrast
it's like Oh cuz oh wow there that
beautiful then it suddenly look what I
am look Who I am
oh yeah that's when you need a drink
yeah I like ten of them that's easy yeah
that's what you need to read it that's
see me to relax
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better what if
you watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one